bonjour à vous merci d'être avec nous en
direct sur rt france alors les
etats-unis qui ont dépassé la barre des
cent vingt mille cas est-ce que donald
trump a pris la mesure de la situation
vous savez que de notre impôt au début
de cette épidémie a semblé vraiment
minimiser la question et ça lui a été
beaucoup reproché et pas seulement par
les démocrates et aux depuis il a une
rhétorique très différent puisque il a
parlé de guerre il a dit le pays est en
guerre donc aujourd'hui en tout cas sur
le plan de la rhétorique
il est vraiment engagée il a compris
vraiment l'importance de ce drame
national
et puis je vous rappelle qu'on est à 30
semaines de l'élection présidentielle
en revanche sur la manière de traiter la
crise est bien là il ya effectivement
beaucoup de beaucoup de polémiques et
notamment sur la question du rapport
entre l'état fédéral et les états ce
sont les états unis d'amérique mais ça
apparaît aujourd'hui comme les états
désunis face au virus
alors il a refusé finalement donald
trump de mettre en quarantaine
l'état de new york l'état le plus touché
aux états unis ça concerne également je
le rappelle les états du connecticut et
du new jersey pourquoi cette décision
finalement alors hier on avait on peut
pas entendu un peu tout et son contraire
il semble que toute la journée il est
réfléchi à cette possibilité de la
quarantaine pour ces trois états que
vous venez de rappeler un new jersey
connecticut new york en fait qu'est-ce
que ça veut dire c'est l'air
métropolitaine de new york
vous l'avez rappelé dans votre question
tout à l'heure c'est plus de la moitié
des cas américains qui sont situés dans
cette aire métropolitaine de new york
alors le président a réfléchi toute la
journée d'hier et ce qu'il allait faire
ce confinement à géométrie variable
cette quarantaine n'ont pas les
quarantaines d'un individu et
quarantaine d'une
lyon métropolitaine il a pris la
décision de ne pas le faire c'est un
choix politique de ne pas tendre
la relation entre l'état fédéral et des
états et vous savez que il ya
aujourd'hui une tension entre plusieurs
états certains états qui disait nous
comme le rhode island par exemple nous
ne voulons pas de genre de voiture avec
des plaques minéralogiques qui viennent
de new york donc si vous vous êtes un
new yorkais que vous arrivez dans le
rhode island et bien la police vous dit
pas question vous rentriez à l'intérieur
de l'état d'ailleurs andrew cuomo le
gouverneur de l'état de new york a dit
que c'était illégal qu'il allait déposer
une plainte contre l'état du rhode
island
parce que selon lui est bien là on
serait en marge de la légalité on ne
respecterait pas la constitution alors
un problème par donald trump le système
des soins aux états unis on voit que la
grogne elles commencent à se faire
entendre de la part des personnels
soignants
il ya aussi la problématique de la
couverture sociale
ça veut dire que donald trump qui va
changer son fusil d'épaulé et
reconnaître finalement les bienfaits de
l'obamacare alors on n'en est pas là là
la question c'est évidemment une
question à la fois de santé mais c'est
surtout aux états unis comme dans
d'autres pays d'ailleurs non pas une
question médicale mais une question du
système de santé
un problème qui est lié à la question de
la santé mais surtout à la question de
l'organisation du système et là il ya un
plan de 2000 ni liards de dollars qui
vient d'être passé entre les
républicains et les démocrates
d'ailleurs il faut rappeler vous vous
souvenez qu'en 2009 les républicains
n'avaient pas signé le plan de relance
d'obama les démocrates ont choisi de
faire de signer avec le président ce
plan très ambitieux 2000 milliards de
dollars et les démocrates ont réussi à
attirer ce plan vert ce que vous dites
un verre un peu plus
d'obama caire vers la prise en compte de
familles qui sont en marge du système
qui n'ont pas de possibilité d'assurance
mais si vous regardez quand même
l'ensemble du plan c'était quand même un
plan qui est majoritairement plutôt
libéral conservateur avec notamment des
dégrèvements fiscaux très très massif et
une aide aux très très grande entreprise
et pas peut-être un peu moins aux
petites et moyennes entreprises donc si
vous voulez la politique continue y
compris en période coronavirus avec ce
plan qui a fait l'objet d'énormément
dalle et venues entre le camp démocrate
et le camp républicain pour trouver et
bien un plan qui puisse être signé par
les uns et par les autres mais la
réalité ce n'est pas la réalité du
chiffre des 2000 milliards de dollars
c'est comment on va concrètement
dépenser cet argent pourrait bien
pouvoir enrayer ce virus qui vous
l'aurez compris aux états unis a cette
particularité
nous sommes dans un état fédéral est
pour le moment la réponse n'est pas
fédéraliser elle est un petit peu à
géométrie variable chaque étage prends
l'exemple par exemple de la floride qui
au cours des dernières heures
vous êtes à new york et vous arrivez en
floride et bien le gouverneur de floride
qui est un très proche de donald trump
vous nous impose une quarantaine avant
de pouvoir et bien vaquer à vos
occupations enfin comme il est possible
de le faire en floride
merci beaucoup françois durpaire après
avoir été en direct avec nous sur rt
frange rappelle que vous êtes historien
et spécialiste des états unis